laissez-moi vous dire qu'il n'y a rien de plus
rock and roll que d'éliminer les
méchants pour le Panama rouge, blanc et bleu
sur le point d'exploser
bienvenue au John
Young
c'est là que j'interviens pour tout nettoyer la
dernière fois que nous étions sur le terrain depuis longtemps  il
y a quelque temps, je m'appelle Rusty,
assure-toi de le frapper à la tête,
je me parlais,
assure-toi de lui casser le cou
après avoir collé,
si jamais on a besoin d'un gars pour un travail difficile, c'était
à Becker, il pourrait devenir Rogue et
moi  Je ne veux pas du sang sur mes mains, du
sang sur tes mains,
es-tu sûr que ce n'est pas de la lotion, il y
a des amis de l'Oncle Sam,
tu cherches des moyens créatifs de financer les
contras, le premier ordre du jour des
concerts de Chopper, ils veulent le chopper en retour,
ils le feront.  donnez-nous des armes et des renseignements,
bien sûr
[Musique]
parlons d'un hélicoptère, nous le verrons
plus tard. Le Panama a beaucoup à offrir à un homme
comme vous,
amusez-vous
et tous ses proches,
il semble que les meurtres de votre bailleur de fonds
le rendent simplement plus en colère,
gentil